bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
sur ce si le gosse alors aujourd'hui je
voulais revenir sur un sujet qui
m'interroge beaucoup sur lequel j'ai
beaucoup débattu avec les amis qui est
celui de l'immersion journalistique ou
du journalisme gonzo
c'est à dire le fait pour un journaliste
de d'infiltrer un domaine un corps de
métier ou de prendre une apparence
particulière pour observer des
discriminations et de rares ondées cela
la première personne pour voir en vous
révéler ce qui serait cash et en tant
que étudiante en sociologie c'est des
pratiques qui me pose problème a choqué
certains aspects un peu problématique
j'ai voulu en parler tout ça suite à la
publication d'un livre est un livre qui
a fait un petit peu débat qui est le
livre flic 2 à 20 ans landreau londres
un journaliste qui a infiltré la police
comme son nom l'indiqué et je voulais
beaucoup de débats autour de celui de
long terme plutôt que la déontologie
journalistique et pour moi dans la
sociologie on peut trouver des réponses
aux débats autour du journalisme
d'infiltration déjà pour poser un peu
les bases le journalisme d'inspiration
ou le journalisme gonzo
c'est une méthode journalistique ou tout
du moins un style d'écriture qui va
faire en sorte que le journaliste se
positionne à la première personne elle
en fait écrit un peu un personnes se
positionne en tant que protagoniste
principal de son enquête donc à l'opposé
en fait du journalisme traditionnel des
reportages etc
on n'a pas une personne concernée qui va
prendre la parole à qui on va donner la
parole du mois mais alain rey à la
sonarges liste se positionne en tant que
sujet principal de l'histoire qu'il a
racontée est autour de 800 gravité des
personnages secondaires qui eux sont
donc dans le cadre d'un jean droz des
policiers de le métier ou des personnes
qui sont exposées réellement j'aurais
bien aux discriminations que le
journaliste entend dénoncer c'est une
pratique qui s'est développée dans la
seconde moitié du 20e siècle de près aux
états unis
du moins qui s'est généralisée à cette
époque là c'est une pratique on trouve
en fait depuis plus ou moins le début de
du journalisme avec en fait ce but de
vouloir révéler ce qui est caché ce
qu'on ne veut pas de montrer en se
disant combattre le journaliste ne peut
pas accéder à certains terrains et que
c'est pour cela qu'il va prétendre faire
partie de ce terrain de cet objet
d'étude en intégrant un corps de métier
ou autres dans les livres qui sont issus
de ces enquêtes en immersion donc en
sous-couverture en quelque sorte on a
toujours ce point commun d'une
subjectivité très assumé de la part des
journalistes avec souvent beaucoup
d'anecdotes mais de manière générale ce
qu'on a c'est surtout tout une première
partie de la deûle ouvrage qui va
concerner la manière dont la journée
s'était préparé son infiltration puis
ensuite on voir le récit de
l'infiltration en tant que tel pour moi
il ya vraiment plusieurs gros soucis
avec le journalisme d'immersion
le premier problème selon moi c'est
vraiment cette idée d'un passing sociale
c'est quelque chose que je trouve très
dérangeant le fait qu'en fait un
journaliste qui très souvent est un
journaliste occidental donc étasunien
européen très souvent un homme est très
souvent lent pour des choses que tu as
qu elles sont donc cet homme ce
journaliste va pouvoir modifier son
apparence modifier son cursus scolaire
ses origines etc pour intégrer un milieu
social qui est plus défavorisés donc il
ya quand même ce toujours ce côté de
passing du niveau de vie ou du moins du
capital culturel assez aisés vers des
classes plus défavorisés que ce soit par
exemple des ouvriers des travailleuses
du sexe ici dans le cadre dans un an de
landreau des policiers voilà ce que
c'est quelque chose d'assez dérangeant
parce qu'on pourrait pas voir la même
chose dans l'autre sens et un livre qui
fait un peu cas d'école pour moi c'est
un ouvrage
que clairement j'ai détesté mais je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi
c'est ce livre qui s'appelle donc dans
la peau d'un intouchable et qui a été
écrit par marc boulet par où commencer
c'est la question du passif social chaud
que c'est un exemple très criants de ce
problème on a ici un homme blanc donc ce
monsieur voulait d'une quarantaine
d'années français qui va se glisser dans
la peau d'un intouchable c'est à dire
d'un indien qui appartient une caste qui
est extrêmement discriminés en inde
qu'on avait grand les dalit le problème
vous race et la question des privilèges
de pourquoi au final on se trouvait des
européens prennent une identité sociale
extrêmement marqué extrêmement durs à
vivre avec beaucoup de discrimination
également il ya un autre ouvrage qui me
qui me fait penser à ces problématiques
c'est le quai de ouistreham qui a été
écrit par florent seront à quai une
journaliste très reconnue et c est là
aussi pour rire un passing social
d'ensemble où cette journaliste a
forcément à un niveau de vie bien
supérieur à celui des femmes de ménage
avec lesquels elle a travaillé dans des
ferries jeu spatial comme rexel choque
vraiment ce rapport un peu de nous on
peut s'infiltrer mais là ce n'est pas
possible
l'autre problématique que je sois
extrêmement dérangeante et qui nous la
sociologie ne pourrait pas se faire
c'est la question fait du consentement
des personnes qui sont enquêtés mon
enquête sociologique ou du moins dans
tous les enquêtes en sciences sociales
bien vraiment se le fait de dire qui on
est et pourquoi on est là c'est la base
tout simplement on ne va pas mentir aux
personnes avec qui on va travailler
parce que eh bien on va raconter leur
vie on va utiliser leur vie et leur
expérience pour produire un objet de
recherche et c'est hyper important que
ces personnes soient au courant pour
qu'elles puissent choisir ce qu'elles
vont nous dire une pas nous dire en fait
c'est la base du consentement tout
simplement
mais bien sûr que ça modifie toujours et
en fait chaque rapport pendant avec un
autre individu modifie la manière dont
on va se raconter tout le travail un
sociologue c'est de réussir à lire entre
les lignes à comprendre ce qui n'est pas
dit où pourquoi les chaussons de vie
telles qu'elles sont et c'est en
journalisme d'immersion j'aurais eu
besoin on vraiment cette fâcheuse
tendance à faire croire qu'il faut
absolument se cache
gêné pour voir la vérité et je trouve ça
très problématique parce que tout
simplement on peut mettre en danger des
gens paraissent un travail en fait je
veux pas de la recherche en sciences
sociales et de comprendre les mécanismes
de discrimination tout comme c'est un
travail de journaliste et je trouve ça
assez problématique d'utiliser la parole
des personnes qui n'ont pas donné leur
accord qui ne sont même pas au courant
et qui se sont confiées à quelqu'un
qu'il considère comme étant leurs amis
et qui un beau jour disparaît et
révèlent une qualité qui honnêtement ne
doit pas être agréable à un temps
franchement je pas se brouiller imaginer
l dans des situations extrêmement
compliqué socialement ce faire un allié
et un ami car je dois raconter sa vie
qu'on va inviter chez soi qui un beau
jour nous vivons va en fait je
démissionne et en fait j'étais
journaliste et qui va publier un livre
c'est quelque chose que j'ai du mal à
comprendre et de là il ya autre chose
qui réunit afin climatiques du platine
sociale et ce après mathy du
consentement c'est que il y a un but
mercantile dans dans ses autres types
dans get autant la recherche en sciences
sociales est là pour faire avancer
l'état de connaissance et de
compréhension de la société et du monde
autour de nous autant le journalisme qui
fait voilà que je vous résume rondot et
les journalistes qui mène ce genre d'
enquête
le fonds dans le but de publier on va
mentir à des gens cachés notre identité
est ensuite utilisé leur expérience et
leur vécu pour faire l'objet d'un livre
qui va rapporter de l'argent et ces gens
qui sont quand même des gens très
défavorisé la part du temps ne verront
jamais l'argent ou du fait qu'ils
résultent de leur expérience du récit de
leur expérience notamment le quai de
ouistreham de florence aubenas vals est
adapté au cinéma et je trouve ça assez
inquiétant de se dire que probablement
les femmes de ménage qui font l'objet du
livre de florence aubenas ne toucheront
pas un centime sur l'argent fait à la
fois par son livre qui a reçu de
nombreux prix et pas le film alors je me
trompe peut-être mais en tout cas c'est
une réflexion que j'ouvre de manière
générale sur la rémunération des
personnes qui sont au coeur même
enquête et son qui donc est n'aurait pas
pu exister l'autre sujet dont je voulais
parler c'est pour revenir sur cette idée
que le pour voir la réalité pour dire la
vérité qui est caché il faut s'infiltrer
dans le cas de notre cher marc boulet il
ya quand même de nombreux livres qui ont
été écrits de première main par des
personnes en touchant en inde des récits
alors que ce soit des romans des
autobiographies
il y à de la documentation de source
première il ya d'ailleurs également des
chercheurs indiens qui sont issus de
cette caste dalit et je trouve ça assez
scandaleux qu'un homme français
ressentent le besoin d'aller ajouté sa
pierre à l'édifice en disant qu' on ne
sait pas ce qui se passe là bas alors
que des personnes dalit racontent deux
premières sources leurs expériences et
s'auto raconte dans des ouvrages
autant je souhaiterais normal de
continuer à envoyer des chercheurs sur
des terrains même des terrains étrangers
mais de se dissimuler de faire croire
que pour raconter une expérience qui est
extrêmement subjective puisque c'est les
classes de marc boulet en tant que faux
20 quintaux jamar filtré on va dire pour
moi n'apportez rien on comprend beaucoup
mieux quand les gens racontent leur
propre histoire
voilà je suis pas du tout pour ses
pratiques d'ailleurs je vous mets en
garde informations les ouvrages de la
littérature dali tôt que vous puissiez
vous renseigner les dires c'est vous
souhaitez mais voilà en tout cas ne
prenez pas celui ci pour sources fiables
nos problèmes qui a selon moi dans ce
texte
vraiment de manière très évidente et le
fait que cette heure se soit éteint la
peau tout comme ça avait été une
pratique dans d'autres emplettes
on a par exemple un journaliste
américaine savall john howard griffin
qui s'était peint en noir pour mieux
comprendre la situation entre nord et
sud des états unis
voilà pour moi c'est vraiment du même
niveau c'est problématique selon moi de
se dire qu'un homme blanc va se teindre
la peau va adopter une atteinte physique
qui est censé le faire passer pour un
fauchage
d'ailleurs je voulais vous lire quelques
extraits à ce sujet s'est décidé dans
trois jours je vais me métamorphoser
alors déjà aucun individu ne peut se
métamorphoser
on peut changer son apparence on peut
passer pour autre se connaît et sait
faire et à ma famille bach aussi dans
une société on en est dans une condition
particulière que tout comme je suis mené
française avec les privilèges qui vont
avec je suis né femme avec les
difficultés qui vont avec et je suis
mais blanche avec les raisons les
privilèges qui vont avec
cet homme aimé avec des privilèges avec
sûrement des difficultés sociales je ne
connais pas sa vie en détail mais on ne
peut pas se teindre la peau et
prétendent que on se métamorphose à ce
bref donc il nous raconte qu'il va faire
un bronzage home et oxyde solar et n que
ça lui a seulement donné un beau al brun
clair je suis moins foncée que je ne
l'espérais
je pense que ça pourrait suffire pour
devenir indien non non comme vous
suffire pour devenir indien on veut pas
devenir indien quand on est un homme
français d'une quarantaine d'années
ensuite il explique je vais me fondre
dans la masse
devenir un atout charme de quelconques
et je vais donc me noircir la peau avec
une teinture capillaire rey était la
muse arguments mais voilà et ensuite il
nous explique qu'il ne va pas se teindre
le tronc seulement les parties visibles
et notamment il me dit je ne veux pas
m'étendre en entier sur tous les organes
génitaux
c'est sur l'autre nocifs et se serait
emparé fastidieux en fait personne ne
t'oblige à sharmarke tu bref il a ce
problème de la couleur de peau
je pense que c'est assez inimaginable
voilà deux de continuer sur leur enquête
aujourd'hui et puis honnêtement qu'on se
le dise la teinture de la peau ne fait
pas illusion ne vous ai pas nous
humblement mieux comprendre ce qu by des
personnes depuis la naissance c'est pas
parce que monsieur marc voulait
fons la peau avec des produits chimiques
que il va comprendre ce que c'est que
d'être né intouchables en inde
voilà mettant les points sur les i
l'autre souci que j'ai avec ce livre
savamment l'idée qu'on a ici un homme
français qui part en inde
pour moi ça relève toute une dynamique
que je qualifie rite d'orientalistes
vraiment cette idée qu'il est plus
facile de se mêler à une société
étrangère et notamment est une société
issue des pays dits du sud parce que
clairement je pense qu'il serait
totalement inimaginable de vendre un
livre ou un intellectuel indien se tint
la peau en loire apprend le français
pendant six mois puis vient en france et
grimés en personne noire se rend dans
une brune du 9-3 et témoigna des
difficultés pour un groupe de jeunes
devant lui quand issus de l'immigration
je jure ça me paraît totalement aberrant
g bassila mouchoirs aussi mais hélas de
me dire que ce monsieur fait son succès
fait sa richesse gagne son salaire à
partir d'un livre qui est écrit avec ce
niveau de considération pour les
classements au sujet des gagner en
qualité
je trouve ça très inquiétant surtout que
marc boulet est coutumier du fait
puisqu'il a écrit un autre livre
s'appelle dans la peau d'un chinois
voilà vous l'aurez compris je n'ai pas
du tout apprécié livres de moins voulait
par contre ce serait beaucoup moins
radicale au sujet de flics qui selon moi
présentait des intérêts en fait pour moi
ce genre d'ouvragé est quand même à lire
avec une forte mise en garde qu'il n'y
ait que il ya une quête de sensationnel
en quelque sorte avec une volonté de
plans dire de montrer d'avoir des
anecdotes est un peu croustillantes
je suis quand même beaucoup plus nuancé
sur ce livre tout d'abord parce que il
ya quelque chose de plus crédible dans
la quête qui est le fait que ces
journalistes a vraiment passé les
concours pour devenir policier et a
vraiment fait ce travail pendant
plusieurs mois en tout sont à filtration
a duré un an
tout comme florence aubenas a vraiment
travaillé en tant que à faire le ménage
à bord des ferries pour autant ça ne
limite pas la question du passif social
même si vincent vendre eux aussi je suis
vraiment dans son livre le fait qu' il
vient d'être l'ami nyokas moyenne qu'il
aurait plus
vraiment devenir policier et cetera bon
bah le fait qu'il n'est pas devenu
policier qu'il habite à paris qu'il est
journaliste
voilà pour moi ça reste quand même
dramatique de putting social en fait pas
vraiment le gros problème dans ce livre
comme dans tous les livres
d'infiltration d'un mystique c'est le
vraiment le fait du consentement
cette idée qu en fait si on avait
demandé aux gens est ce que vous voulez
parler de comment ça se passe dans votre
métier
est ce que vous vous accepté de répondre
à des questions etc et bien si les on
dit oui et bien d'accord s'ils disent
non et bien c'est qu'ils ont des raisons
bien non tout simplement et je trouve ça
assez fou de vouloir à tout prix exposer
la vie de personnes dans le cadre des
policiers en france c'est que dans une
profession relativement protégé mais
c'est un journaliste infiltré par
exemple des activistes d'un certain
groupe politique dans certains pays
en fait ça peut mettre tout simplement
en danger de mort des personnes qu'on
interroge je vous a vraiment une très
irresponsable en fait dans certains cas
de la part d'un journaliste de pouvoir
rechercher soi-disant une forme de
vérité au prix de la protection des
personnes qui n'ont jamais sauté être
exposé et je pense que ça doit rester
quand même un choix de la personne qui
exerce maintenant ce métier et qui va
continuer de l'exercer une fois
l'infiltration terminé pour autant sur
les points de vue positif
je trouve que c'est un lieu quand même
très instructive sur le fonctionnement
de la police parce que c'est quand même
un domaine où il n'y a pas énormément de
source pour autant il ya quand même des
sources universitaires beaucoup plus
fiable est également une source
d'anciens policiers qui ont témoigné par
la suite après avoir quitté la police et
je pense que ces témoignages ont plus
intéressant que celui ci ça vraiment la
question selon moi deux comme en
témoigne et comment montrer les
mécanismes à l'intérieur de corps de
métier qui reste très fermé et où il est
difficile d'entendre une parole une
parole objective on va dire autant cet
ouvrage n'est pas objectif ça raconte
l'histoire deux valeureux dans son
expérience pour devenir policière donc
ce que je voulais dire on va dire pour
résumer un petit peu pour conclure cette
vidéo c'est que analystes ne sera jamais
ce qui est la réalité d'une personne
qui vibrations des discussions très fort
les travailleuses du sexe savent quelle
est la réalité
tout comme les réfugiés à calais savent
quelle est la réalité
les hommes politiques savent quelle
pièce se joue dans le théâtre même de
l'assemblée et du gouvernement c'est pas
juste une raison ou une autre c'est la
qualité des personnes pauvres ex-amant
défavorisés très discriminés et c des
personnes qui ne sont pas certes pas
explosé dans l'espace médiatique c'est
juste qu'on ne donne pas la voie à ces
personnes là et je pense qu'ils sont là
proposer beaucoup dire énorme mais
certains diraient oui et que on a plutôt
valoriser les témoignages de sources
premières ou de la recherche
universitaire pour mieux comprendre les
mécanismes de discrimination et avoir
des témoignages de premier plan deux
premières sources et je trouve qu'il ya
vraiment un route est un peu malsain et
une quête du sensationnel dans le
journalisme d'infiltration d'immersion
jeunesse bronzo au moins faire honneur
aux personnes qui sont discriminés et
qui vivent des quotidiens très difficile
c'est citer leurs noms
c'est les laisser parler pour eux même
dire leur vérité ne va parler à leur
place et c'est surtout de ne pas exposer
à des fins mercantiles leur vie à
l'invention
surtout que ces ouvrages sont produits
par et pour les formes d'élite culturel
souvent un parisienne est aisée et voilà
je pour moi ils sont les objets d'un
livre qui
la plupart ne pourront pas lire ou
n'auront pas accès et sur lequel de
toute façon n'ont pas leur mot à dire
mais je trouve ça vraiment problématique
voilà évidemment il ya encore beaucoup à
dire sur ce sujet et j'espère que ça
vous aurait intéressé en tout cas j'ai
apprécié partager ma réflexion ce sujet
avec vous et j'espère que l'on pourra
débattre un petit peu en commentaire à
ce sujet je vous mets quelques
références un petit peu universitaire au
sujet du journalisme gonzo de manière
générale sur tous les sujets que j'ai
évoquées pour qu'on puisse y aller plus
loin si vous souhaitez et puis les ânes
devrait formuler dans un autre exercice
assure le boss
[Musique]